[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans la grande
interview aujourd'hui je vais rencontrer
ici à bamako deborah alaoui al masri
alors elle est la compagne d'olivier
dubois olivier dubois est actuellement
le dernier otage français détenu dans le
monde il a été capturé par un groupe
djihadiste dans la zone de gao il y a
huit mois alors qu'il faisait son métier
de journaliste olivier dubois a toujours
été quelqu'un de terrain d'ailleurs
quand déborah et lui se sont rencontrés
la première fois olivier quasiment
immédiatement partis couvrir un attentat
c'était le 20 novembre 2015 contre
l'hôtel radisson blu à bamako il en a
ramené des images c'est ça qui l'a fait
connaître deborah nous raconte
[Musique]
il s'est installé ici vous étiez avec
eux ici il ya cet attentat au radisson
il va couvrir cette attente un couvent
cet attentat il a pas de rédac il a rien
d'accord ils causent la quant à moi je
me rappelle de la scène je me lève je
crois qu il était 7 heures 7 heures 30
puis olivier il a toujours un sac noir
qui met en bandoulière tout le temps
parce qu'il a son appareil tous ces
trucs ses papiers son enregistreur et la
billingham l'aller les sacs de
photographes et puis je en fait je me
vois marché dans le couloir et je le
vois sabieh jeudi mais tu vas où parce
que moi moi je travaille mais olivier
lui il y beaucoup il mais il sort pas
parce qu'il n'a pas besoin de il n'a pas
de rendez vous spécialement pas du tout
à cette heure-là
dit un attentat et du coup tout de suite
le premier papier moi j'ai peur
mais qui part en fait j'ai peur mais il
dit fais moi confiance c'est mon travail
et puis paris couvre il écrit un papier
qui a été saluée parce que c'était un
des seuls qui étaient là-bas des débuts
qui a pu comprendre qui a pu parler de
ça et c'est comme ça qu'ils commencent à
journaldumali puisqu'il avait rencontré
une journaliste
une journaliste là bas et quand ce
papier tu es prêt il les appelait leur a
dit écoutez j'ai un papier j'ai des
photos j'étais sur place j'étais sur
place et c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
commencé à travailler d'accord et
ensuite sa carrière pour le suivant il a
attiré l'attention des médias français
où il est associé de solliciter comment
ça s'est passé je ne sais pas exactement
comment c'est fait
la collaboration parce que moi je rentre
pas dans ces détails là il travaillait
au journal du mali il était rédac chef
du web et un moment donné je pense qu'il
sentait qu'il avait fait le tour de ce
qu'ils voulaient faire et et puis lui ce
qu'il voulait c'était vraiment retourner
à ce qu'il aime c'est la recherche
l'enquète olivier c'est pas quelqu'un du
scoop en fait c'est pas son truc c'est
pas de faire des articles sur du scoop
c'est de faire de l'investigation de
faire de l' enquête de comprendre ce qui
se passe donc du coup pour faire ça faut
du temps quand on est rédac'chef il
partait le matin à 7h30 il revenait à
19h mai à 19 heures il était dans son
bureau encore jusqu'à 22 heures à
peaufiner les choses à peaufiner des
papiers quand on fait ça on ne fait pas
ce qu'on aime et à un moment donné voilà
il s'est posé la question se disant bon
ben maintenant ce que je veux faire
c'est c'est
c'est de l'investigation et c'est
d'aller sur des papiers poussée des
enquêtes lui c'est ça son travail là
olivier quand il écrit il a toujours
cette volonté de faire avancer les
choses de dénouer des situations c'est
ceux à qui croit profondément
si les journalistes c'est parce qu'il
sait que les journalistes ont un devoir
d'informer de comprendre le faire
comprendre de faire comprendre parce que
parce qu'il ya tellement de gens qui
vivent dans des pays sans comprendre ce
qui se passe juste parce que soit ils
ont des médias qui sont un peu influencé
au parce que ils n'ont pas une une image
objective donc il reste
dans ce à quoi il était un journaliste
expérimenté quelqu'un qui aimait le
terrain
parfois est-ce que mise à part cet
épisode du radisson vous aviez peur pour
lui vous aviez peur pour sa vie je
n'avais pas peur j'ai pas peur parce que
je lui fais confiance il a toujours été
au coeur de l'information
comme je vous ai expliqué
sa première quand je découvre ollivier
journaliste c'est lors d'un attentat moi
j'ai toujours connu olivier qui
écrivaient des sujets de société
des choses très neutre et
du coup la première fois que la première
fois qu'il part écrire un papier
forcément j'ai peur mais il me rassure
je sui team dit déborah je sais ce que
je fais c'est mon travail tu dois me
laisser y aller je prendrai pas de
risques et la première fois qu'il part
moi je suis je suis très stressée je
suis pas bien j'ai peur on m'appelle
comme il était un des seuls journalistes
aussi quand les chaînes de télé sont
arrivés bfm tout ça on le voyait à la
télé donc les gens nous disaient mais on
voit olivier qui ce qui se passe et puis
je pense que cette première expérience
cm à elle m'a fait comprendre que je
devais lui faire confiance parce que
c'est son métier chaque métier un risque
et je dois les faire confiance de cas
chaque fois qu'il a été en déplacement
ou qu'il a couvert des sujets qui
étaient un peu peut-être
on va dire un peu risqué il m'a toujours
mis en confiance ce qui sait ce qui
s'est passé c'est ce qui s'est passé
cette fois-ci ils étaient sur le terrain
vous communiquiez j'imagine que vous
appelez régulièrement pour donner des
nouvelles ça dépend des déplacements
c'est à dire que
pour tous les déplacements
il y avait des nouvelles un minimum de
nouvelles pour ce déplacement là il
était convenu que je n'aurai aucune
nouvelle jusqu'à son retour
vous saviez qu'il allait rencontrer
je ne savais pas ce que c'était le jeu
nîmes
j'ai un peu honte de le dire mais je vis
au mali
sans vraiment comprendre
la situation lourde du moi je la
comprenais pas cette situation parce que
les gens peuvent pour pourront
comprendre quand on vit à bamako on est
centré sur bamako et tout le reste c'est
un peu loin et c'est difficile d'avoir
l'information alors j'avais olivier qui
essayait de me sensibiliser mais moi je
suis syrienne
j'ai arrêté de regarder l'information en
au début du conflit en 2010 après juste
après 2010
parce que ça m'a dépassé j'ai été je
partager la vie d'un journaliste sans
m'informer à l'actualité donc quand
quand ils me donnent son protocole de
sécurité puisqu'il me laissait toujours
un protocole de sécurité et qui m'écrit
qui doit rencontrer je n'ai aucune idée
de qui c'est je ne sais pas parce que je
lui fais confiance je ne maîtrise pas
tout c'est tout c'est tout tout c'est
comment dire toutes ces situations
et
est maintenant que je suis au courant de
de tout ça et que je suis plus sur
l'actualité je pense que que vraiment
tout le mali devrait prendre ces
histoires a vraiment à coeur au delà
d'olivier parce que c'est
vous aviez entendu parler d'al qaïda
j'avais entendu parler bien sûr d'al
qaïda mais je ne savais pas que que
que ce groupe était affilié je
connaissais même pas l'existence de ce
groupe et j'ai honte de le dire parce
que souvent on me l'a dit ça a été ça a
été une lourde charge en fait parce
qu'on m'a dit mais attends quand tu as
su qu'ils allaient voir pourquoi tu ne
l'a pas empêchée mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que quand olivier
parent au pays dogon
c'est un homme je lui dis je lui fait
confiance en fait si me dis que ça va se
passer comme ça je sais qu'il a des
enfants je sais qu'ils prévoient les
rythmes moi je ne connais pas la
situation je ne connais pas chaque
déplacement qu'il l'a fait il était
réfléchie chaque fois qu'il était dans
une manifestation et prenez ces
précautions pendant les événements de
badalabougou
il était là bas aussi toute la nuit
ça fait partie du métier de journaliste
s'il n'y a pas des gens qui se lèvent et
qui vont raconter ce qui se passe on
sait pas et on nous raconte n'importe
quoi
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois
quelles sont les nouvelles
les nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement et c'est difficile c'est
très très dur c'est très lourd on sent
très très seul je me sens très seul
parce que je sais que je peux compter
sincèrement sur le mallié sur la france
j'ai confiance et mes deux pays et je
suis né en france je vis au mali j'aime
ces deux pays et ils me l'ont dit la
libération d'olivier c'est une
préoccupation parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
doivent retourner à la maison auprès de
ses enfants
mais il travaille dans la discrétion
parce que ce sont des états parce que ce
sont des ce sont des situations qui sont
très sérieuses et c'est décide cdc des
situations des discussions qui sont très
fébriles
tous qui nous disent qu'ils ne peuvent
pas nous dire c'est tout ce qu'on sait
peu après sa capture
il ya eu une vidéo il est apparu l'a dit
ce qui lui arrivait depuis vous l'avez
jamais revu en vidéo i
on n'a jamais eu de vidéos les dernières
nouvelles qu'on m'a est ce que je prends
comme des nouvelles il y à un
journaliste de france 24
wassim nasa
qui est un spécialiste on le sait de la
zone qui a une
une déclaration
d'un haut membre de ses ravisseurs qui
dit en fait ça commence par l'otage et
disons que l'otage est avec nous donc
déjà juste le et ce petit mot es clé ça
me fait pour moi ça c'est une c'est une
preuve de vie
juste cette déclaration là
donc pour moi ce sont les dernières
nouvelles que j'ai d'olivier cette
déclaration on dit qu'il est
est ce que vous pouvez rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs qui connaissent pas
forcément quelques circonstances de cet
enlèvement comment vous avez appris la
nouvelle comment ça s'est passé pour
vous parce qu'elle n'a pas été
communiquée tout de suite non elle n'a
pas été communiquée tout de suite parce
qu'en fait
pour être assez sincère on ne savait pas
on ne savait pas si c'était un
enlèvement
parce qu'il avait pris beaucoup de
précautions
et on s'était juste dit que un problème
technique peut arriver
c'est pas la première fois que des
journalistes avait été invité et qui
avait pu revenir et faire leurs
reportages
donc au début on en a pas parlé parce
qu'on se disait qu' il ya peut-être eu
un problème et qu'il allait revenir
c'est vrai que le temps a été très
longue puisque de base c'était un
rendez-vous de 45 minutes qui était
prévu et dans la ville de gao c'était
pas prévu qu'ils sortent à l'extérieur
de gao et ce n'était pas prévu que ce
soit beaucoup plus long mais
on avait et on a toujours et ça c'est
important on avait espoir
qu'ils puissent revenir
donc il ya eu vraiment une solidarité
des journalistes qui se sont dit ben
voilà on va attendre de voir on va pas
risquer quelque chose de compliqué pour
lui s'il est juste en train de faire son
travail
donc malheureusement quand la vidéo est
paru sur les réseaux sociaux c'est là
qu'on a eu la confirmation
qu'il a été enlevé mais jusqu'à cette
vidéo je ne pensais pas que cette non
j'avais de l'espoir je pensais qu'à tout
moment il allait revenir
comment vous en avait parlé à vos
enfants
alors
ma fille c'est un peu
tiens
à dire c'est un sourire jaune parce que
si elle l'a pris c'est à cause des
journalistes
le jour où le jour où dans la vidéo
alors je m'effondre
est entendu
et j'ai des amis ici des soeurs qui sont
qui ont tout de suite débarquer chez moi
qui sont venus qui m'ont relevé limite
qui m'ont nous dans la douche pour me
dire non c'est pas aujourd'hui où tu
tombes c'est pas aujourd'hui
donc je me suis relevé j'ai j'ai été en
ville pour aller voir les autorités
allaient voir qu'est ce qui se passait
et donc j'avais organisé avec une amie
que les enfants aller chez elle pour
l'après midi comme il avait pas école et
qu'ils puissent profiter à l'époque on
n'avait pas de maison qu'ils puissent
profiter de la piscine tout ça est en
fait en revenant de chez mon avocat je
reçois un appel de ma fille qui me dit
et répète maman maman et je comprends
pas ce qui se passe je pensais que
c'était un problème de réseau juridique
qu'est ce qu'il ya et elle me dit il ya
un journaliste qui a été enlevé et à
s'écroule je l'entends pleurer elle
savait qu olivier aller à fait ce
déplacement puisque olivier ans on a
parlé il en a parlé avec elle il lui a
dit je vais me déplacer je vais aller
essayer de comprendre ça tu vois c'est
ça mon travail il faut pas s'inquiéter
chaque déplacement il en a parlé avec
nous sans parler qu'il organise qui va
voir exactement mais son travail ici
c'est sais c'est pas un tabou et sa
fille s'intéresser à son travail bien
sûr bien sûr et on on pouvait des fois
même même se moquer de lui des fois on
était chacun s'était pas il n'y avait
pas de tabous par rapport à ça et en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que sur le
smartphone quand on fait comme ça sur
gauche sur android on a les news et elle
a fait ça et elle a vu la photo elle a
refusé de voir la vidéo
elle pour elle c'est encore assez très
difficile elle est dans le mutisme vous
allez aussi un petit garçon qui a 5 ans
comment un petit garçon explique que son
papa et puis là alors bah en fait
je lui ai expliqué que c'était
comme dans les films de super héros
que des fois le héros principal le plus
gentil le plus fort il est emmené loin
et que ses amis ils se réjouissent ils
se liguent pour aller le chercher
il n'ya pas de méchants il n'y a pas de
tout ça il ya ma fille par exemple n'a
pas voulu voir la vidéo mon fils
la regarder
et
voilà il a beaucoup de questions tout ça
est pour lui voilà on est dans une dans
une histoire de super-héros et pour vous
pouvez vous partager par exemple à
chaque fois que je rencontre des gens et
que je peux lui permettre de rencontrer
des gens qui sont là qui nous
soutiennent je lui dis bah ça c'est un
super héros qui nous aident pour papa ça
permet de le rassurer sur le fait que
des gens continuent à chercher son père
exactement par exemple aujourd'hui chez
ben là c'est bientôt noël c'est très
lourd mais j'ai commandé c'est des
petits trucs mais j'ai commandé une
vidéo vous savez sur internet du père
noël où il lui donne beaucoup de courage
et où dit il lui donne le secret que lui
aussi est un super héros qui est pour
papa est que cette année il faut mettre
de gâteaux et qui lui promet qu'ils
eurent à lui rapporter son gâteau
là où il est à son anniversaire il ya un
facteur qui est venu lui dépose un
cadeau de papa bien entendu papa n'a pas
envoyé de cadeaux mais oui papa était là
papa est là tous les jours olivier ont
fait que des recettes qu'il aime on
pense à lui tout le temps on y
il est il a jamais quitté nos villes a
jamais quitté nos coeurs à votre avis
quelles sont ses conditions de détention
aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est sûr elles sont très
difficiles parce que les anciens otages
ont pu nous
il racontait la vie dans le désert tout
le temps en mouvement c'est très
difficile ils sont coupés de tout je
reçois souvent des questions de
personnes qui me demandent mais est ce
que tu es en contact avec lui
je pense que les gens se rendent pas que
dans la situation dans laquelle il est
il n'est pas dans un hôtel
capturé avec un téléphone et il peut
nous donner des nouvelles non il est
tout le temps et on le sait pas ce que
c'est les anciens otages qui nous le
raconter il est tout le temps en
mouvement il est tout le temps en train
de faire des camps de défaire des camps
de faire un feu pour manger alors bien
entendu où
je sais de par ce qu'on a pu me raconter
qu'il a des des comment dire des
conditions de vie qui sont très
rudimentaires et très dur j'espère
vraiment de tout mon coeur qui qui
reçoit notre énergie dans son coeur et
aussi j'espère qu'ils aient acquis la
accès aussi à nos différentes
interventions et c'est pour ça que même
si je suis très fatigué et ça me coûte 1
vous savez moi c'est pas mon métier de
faire des interviews c'est pas mon
métier de de faire des jolies phrases et
de faire des jeux les discours c'est pas
ça mon métier moi je transporte des
choses je mets des choses dans un camion
et je les amène sais c'est pas mon c'est
pas mon métier et est du coup en tout
cas gg
j'essaye de lui de lui communiquer des
messages j'espère qu'ils et j'essaye de
répondre aux demandes pour qu'il puisse
s'entendre parce que les anciens otages
l'audi l'on dit ce qui permettait de de
les faire tenir c'est d'avoir échos de
la mobilisation qui se faisait pour eux
d'inconnus
c'était des fois sur celui exactement
des fois c'était entendre simplement la
voix d'un de ses proches ou peut-être on
allait lui dire tout simplement tiens ya
ton papa qui a fait une interview il
était jolie vous voyez et c'est ce genre
c'est pour ça que que même si ça me
coûtait que c'est très difficile pour
moi parce que j'ai la pression
médiatique parce que parce que si je
fais une erreur de français je sais
qu'on a tous le jugement aussi des gens
qui vous regardent moi j'essaye de faire
de mon mieux je suis tout simplement
pour qu'ils m'entendent parce que c'est
ça mon travail
c'est la france et le mali où la france
ou le mali qui vont libérer olivier g
pas ce pouvoir de libérer mais par
contre j'ai le devoir de mobilisation et
ça je le laisse je ne l'abandonnerai
part je ne laisserai pas je ferai
toujours tout pour qu'ils puissent
montant de la wii mais qu'ils sachent
que je me bats et que jamais je
l'abandonnerai jamais où est ce que vous
avez de l'espoir autour de la libération
de lier pour cette visite moi j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir et quand je le dis je
suis très sincère je connais la force du
mali je sais ce qu'ils font et je
connais la force de la france aussi il
suffit juste de regarder le bilan de
cette dernière année on a eu beaucoup de
libération dizaines d'otages connus ont
été libérés on ne sait pas sur ceux qui
ne sont pas aussi connus parce que il ya
il ya qu'il ya une
une une analyse qui était qui a été
sorti ya pas très longtemps et qui
parlait du nombre de personnes qui ont
été qui ont été enlevés dans la région
oui que le sol qui est colossal mais
malheureusement on n'entend jamais
parler malheureusement on n'entend pas
parler mais on n'entend pas parler que
ces personnes sont libérées vous voyez
on a eu quand même des très belles des
très belles libération en un laps de
temps assez court
délibération qui nous ont fait beaucoup
de bien même en termes même en tant que
citoyens
toutes les libérations que ce soit faux
soumaïla cissé sophie pétrole 1 que ce
soit le chanteur dr kane que ce soit sur
gloria même les autres et les italiens
l'échiné quand on voit cette nouvelle où
ça nous rassure ça nous ça nous fait
quelque chose au coeur et je parle même
pas en tant que moi compagne d'olivier
dubois je parle en tant que citoyenne
démocrate et je sais qu'ils ont ce
pouvoir là mais je sais que chaque
situation est différente et chaque
situation à son degré de sensibilité
donc j'ai confiance en le mali et je
pense que je serais pas un peu comment
dire
un peu trop hautaine de dire que la
capacité d'action de la france n'est
même pas à démontrer je veux dire j'ai
même pas besoin de dons c'est
indiscutable je sais que que la france
est capable de mener à bien ces
discussions diplomatiques je dis bien
discussions diplomatiques parce que je
ne souhaite pas d'intervention militaire
ça je l' ai dit dès le début à quiconque
a pu montant de n'importe quelle
autorité et sur les médias je ne
souhaite pas d'intervention militaire ça
c'est ma plus grande phobie et c'est ce
qui m'empêche de dormir à chaque fois
que je vois une annonce de
neutralisation ou de quoi que ce soit je
suis tout le temps en train de me poser
la question où est olivier donc ça moi
je ne souhaite que des discussions
diplomatiques
et oui j'ai confiance en la france et au
mali pour qu'elle soit menée vous avez
les docks et sophie petrona
qui a été libéré donc après quatre
rondes avec
soumaila cissé après quatre ans de
détention que pensez vous du fait
qu'elle ait voulu revenir au mali
est ce que ça vous a choqué
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est une question qui est très sensible
parce que son retour a fait polémique
mais moi je vois
je vois l'image comme celle ci je ne
suis pas dans ses dents dans la sphère
géopolitique
je ne suis pas dans les relations
france mali
tout ce que je vois c'est que c'est une
dame qui a passé toute sa vie à se
sacrifier pour les enfants au mali
moi ça fait cinq ans six ans même que je
vis ici
quand on a un quotidien ici c'est parce
qu'on aime le pays et qu'on aime ou on
aime la france et j'aime aussi le mali
je ne m'en suis jamais caché ce sont
deux pays qui sont extrêmement chers à
mon coeur
donc comme je le disais ce fils est une
dame qui a passé toute sa vie à
s'occuper des enfants aujourd'hui elle
est à l'âge de la retraite moi je me
suis mise à sa place et sont sans aucune
pensée de vouvoyer par rapport à la
politique et l'engagement français
militaires tout ça c'est ce je me suis
juste mis à la place de cette mamie qui
a dû se retrouver dans son appartement
en suisse et puis ne sentir qu'elle
qu'elle m'aide plus personne et qu'elle
a abandonné sa fille au mali
donc je dis pas que je suis d'accord
avec elle sur le fait qu'elle soit
revenu et quand même 200 djihadistes qui
ont été libérés contreuse pour sa
libération il ya aussi les
militaires qui ont été ou un jeu qui se
sont sentis écoutés je ne suis pas là la
porte-parole de de sophie petrona et
je ne souhaite pas l'être mais je pense
qu'il est important que les choses
soient recadrer
il n'y a pas eu 200 libération pour
sophie petro n'a donc pour soultz mais
là s'il forme un ensemble des tâches aux
otages bien sûr mais aujourd'hui c'est
sophie petronas qu'on charge vous voyez
c'est une affaire qui est très sensible
je sais que ça a fâché beaucoup de gens
effectivement il ya déjà des soldats
français qui sont là et qui se battent
chaque jour pour notre sécurité
mais elle n'était pas responsable de ça
vous voyez est aujourd'hui le fait
qu'elles soient revenus ou pas moi j'ai
aucun jugement sur ça je dis pas que
c'est la chose à faire
mais je peux la comprendre moi-même si
vous me posez la question aujourd'hui
deborah quand olivier va revenir
qu'est-ce que vous ferais je vous
répondrais je ferai ce qu'olivier voudra
si olivier décide qu'on reste à bamako
et qui pensent que les conditions
sécuritaires sont suffisantes pour qu'on
puisse continuer continuer notre vie au
mali pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a
continuerait pas au mali mais s'il juge
que les conditions sécuritaires mérite
qu'on doit on mérite qu'on sorte du mali
je le serai mais moi aujourd'hui vous
voyez je suis ici avec mes enfants oui
c'est un peu ça secret vous bien j'ai
depuis qu'il est en détention non j'ai
pas peur alors évidemment être une femme
seule dans une maison avec des enfants
ça fait peur ne pas avoir de de la
présence de son conjoint à la maison
bien sûr que ça fait peur mais ce que
j'ai peur pour ma sécurité à bamako non
pas du tout pas du tout vous savez c'est
ça aussi on âme
quand on parle du retour de sophie
petrona on a l'impression que c'est la
seule française qui vit à bamako et
qu'elle est en danger de mort à tout
instant
il ya quand même eu 8000 français et ça
c'est que les français je parle pas des
américains je parle pas des européens je
ne parle pas des autres pays il ya une
vie ici à bamako on peut la comprendre
que si on vient ici
et je peux vous dire que je suis plus en
sécurité ah je me sens plus en sécurité
ici à bamako que qu'ailleurs c'est chez
moi en famille
petro n'a été aussi enfin été critiquée
par le tête un projet de revenir là où
elle habitait avant là où elle a été
détenue je le fait qu'elle soit bamako
il n'y a pas de problème sur sa personne
enfin si moi vraiment c'est comme je
vous dis je suis pas le porte parole de
leur famille mais je crois que son fils
a été assez clair
son fils quand il s'est exprimé il a
clairement dit que sa mère souhaitait
une vie paisible à bamako est-ce qu'elle
a le droit à cette vie paisible au moins
je peux pas je peux pas voilà mais il a
quand même il a quand même dit que le
projet était qu'elle reste à bamako
qu'est ce que vous lui avez parlé non
non jamais non
chez compris à travers
les déclarations de son fils un public
qu'elle souhaitait juste une petite vie
paisible dans sa petite maison avec sa
fille
et je ne je ne veux pas la troubler dans
dance qu'elle a retrouvé aujourd'hui
c'est u c'est une épreuve qui est pas
facile moi je suis donc je suis dedans
et je sais à quel point c'est impactant
pour tous les gens qui m'entourent parce
que c'est très lourd et bien sûr si un
jour elle m'invite à boire le thé bien
entendu que je viendrais la voir mais je
pense que après tout ce qu'elle a vécu
elle mérite ça paie c'était pas facile
quand même puis être une femme vous
savez moi je suis maire
c'est pas évident
mais merci beaucoup en tout cas de nous
avoir reçus merci d'avoir accepté de
nous livrer votre témoignage et bon
courage merci
[Musique]
je